في ظروف استثنائيه اختلطت فيها تكبيرات
عيد الفطر المبارك من المساجد بعزيز
المدافع واصوات الرصاص عاش السودانيون هنا
في جنوب الخرطوم ليله مرعبه بالامس وهذا
الصباح في عيد الفطر المبارك كان يتوقع
البعض ان تكون هذا العيد ان يكون هذا
العيد مناسبه لصلحي والسلام ووقف دائما
لاطلاق النار الموصلون هنا دعوا الاطراف
المتحاربه رئيس مجلس السياده ونائبه في
محاوله لان يكون هذا العيد مناسبه ايضا
لوقت دائم لاطلاق النار وتحقيق المصالحه
بينهم والدخول في حوار هذه المشاهد التي
نروها الان هو هذا العدد المحدود من اهالي
هذه المنطقه في جنوب الخرطوم حاولوا
الوصول الى المسجد ولكن خيم عليهم الحزن
هذه المره والظروف هذه الاستثنائيه هم
يعيشون هذا العيد
بهذا الطعم ويتمنون ان يكون مناسبه لوقت
الحرب الطاهر المرضي الجزيره الخرط